what's the structure of Consciousness
and can it be instantiated by
non-biological systems and we shouldn't
just sit back and go oh it's not
biological so this is a silly fantasy
and we shouldn't investigate I'm not
saying that it is illogical or
impossible what I'm saying is that we
have absolutely no reason to take the
question seriously
[Music]
I've started in my book artificial you
to develop tests for Consciousness
um so one would be to box in the AI at
the r d stage boxing in an AI is a
strategy in AI safety so that means that
you deny the AI access to the internet
facts about human Minds Consciousness it
doesn't have access like you know Lambda
did to Wikipedia
um and you ask it questions to see if it
seems conscious and if it does and it
didn't have access to those kinds of
facts then I think
in that case in the case of that system
we need to be very careful how we treat
it ethically it may be conscious for all
we know I think this is utter and
complete fantasy ungrounded in fact and
ungrounded in reason
um it is a question of the following
form we know living beings are conscious
right so why can't a computer be
conscious we have to be humble about
that well let me illustrate the same
question in other words
we know birds fly when they flap their
limbs right so we have to be humble
about that and so why can't I fly if I
flap my limbs well the answer is a bird
and me are completely different things
now I'm not endorsing necessarily
biological naturalism as a philosophical
position but I recognize that what we
call biology in nature is a very complex
very unique very specific thing that is
unlike anything else in nature there is
nothing in nature that is not metabolism
that looks like metabolism even the
complex patterns of electromagnetic
fields in the sun's Corona they do not
look like metabolism there is nothing
that does and I think acknowledging this
empirical observation this empirical
fact is important and we shouldn't
confuse humbleness with a kind of
open-mindedness that opens the gates for
all kinds of fantasies that we have
absolutely no reason to entertain
whatsoever let me just point out that
if the Wright brothers said that if they
said oh only biological entities I.E
birds can fly and we can't make the leap
to
flight in airplanes we wouldn't have
airplanes Right Flight is multiply
realizable as the philosophers you know
to use theirs their jargon here it can
be instantiated by biological and
non-biological systems and I think it's
a very important question
what's the structure of Consciousness
and can it be instantiated by
non-biological systems and we shouldn't
just sit back and go oh it's not
biological so this is a silly fantasy
and we shouldn't investigate whether
entities which are going to be very soon
smarter than us and they're going to
claim their Consciousness quite possibly
because their advantages to doing so
aren't conscious uh the question of
flight is a question of behavior and
it's fairly observable and we understand
the mechanics of flight when it comes to
Consciousness it's a question of being
are you conscious or not it's not about
manifested behavior and we do not
understand from a reductive perspective
how Consciousness can be reduced to to
anything so to say that a computer that
seems to simulate or emulate the
patterns of information flow in a human
brain is conscious is entirely analogous
to saying that if I run a accurate
simulation of kidney function on my
computer my computer will urinate on my
desk I'm not saying that it is illogical
or impossible what I'm saying is that we
have absolutely no reason to take the
question seriously on the basis of
reason and and empirical data okay
okay trying to save
Sims machines to build AGI so here I'm
thinking of Yeshua bengio's lab and at
my Center uh you know Larry and uh
Eleanor Blum you know touring Award
winner Lawrence Blum they're trying to
build conscious Ai and they insist that
doing so will yield the felt quality of
experience as well as AGI so according
to Authority
your opinion to Authority a known
fallacy if you argue the points that
that was just a moment
all I'm
C approach to machine Consciousness and
I'm saying that some what I was trying
to get to was that some simulations like
the simulations they're building we need
to keep it open that certain AGI
simulations may actually yield machines
with phenomenal Consciousness they're
claiming it and we can't close the door
on it immediately just by calling it a
fantasy which you know isn't much of a
um great argument form either